i think we've come a long way as far as  latino representation but we still got a  long way to go  [Music]  i'm just you know a young latino kid  that wasn't supposed to make it  i didn't notice i was different until i  went to the olympics and they were like  did you know you're the first u.s latina  to be a part of the olympic team in over  30 years  we went to these auditions there was a  lot of little white kids and one  there comes my little latin boy then he  didn't get the part  i was realizing that not only could i be  an ambassador for nasa  but women of color and people that just  aren't seen very much at all  it's not that it's impossible i'm just  going to have to work a little harder to  do it  change is not only possible but it is  necessary right here right now in this  [Music]  moment  [Music]  you